Put me into minds.
Even mediocre minds operate better under
stimulus.
Cod Canadian is a Canadian and you can't
take away
someone got into.
Barack Obama has systematically rebuild
the trust of the world in our
willingness to work through the Security
Council and other institutions.
You must not talk to anybody in the
world,
any of our allies,
if whatever you want to call this
system,
a mafia,
state of feudal empire,
it's a disaster for ordinary Russians.
Brilliant minds getting mediocre minds
operate better under stimulus.
Cod Canadian is a Canadian and you can't
take away away,
has systematically rebuild the trust of
the world in our willingness to work
through the Security Council and other
institution.
You must not talk to anybody in the
world,
any of our allies,
whatever you want to call this system,
a mafia,
state of feudal empire.
It's a disaster for ordinary Russians.
I think that's the kind of hypocritical
argument that if I were tiny,
I find quite annoying.
I need,
but in Belize you can beat it.
Described it's been bad.
Again,
management,
science and religion are not
incompatible.
Religion Forces Nice people to do unkind
things.
Amen.
Obsolete.
Uh,
Mike conclusion to this question is,
no,
I won't let you be.
You
show me yours pretext.
I quoted them saying,
show me the free program.
You can keep screaming,
man,
and it doesn't change the points.
We do not want sympathy.
We did not want pity.
We want opportunities.
It's an appalling slander to me,
to the Muslim religion.
I never said the word Muslim in my film,
the nation.
It was a Muslim free form in nature.
It is that kind of restraint.
It is that kind of sober minded,
sensible,
intelligent foreign policy that Obama
represents.
So I guess what I'm telling you is he
sort of a closet Canadian vote for him
for God.
Sorry
Ladies and gentlemen and welcome.
My name is right here.
Griffis since my privilege that I have
the opportunity to
moderate tonight's debates and to act as
your organizer,
I want to start by welcoming the North
American.
Why television audience tuning in right
now across Canada on Seapak,
Canada's public affairs channel c span
across the continental United States and
on CBC radio ideas,
a warm hello also to our online audience
watching
this
debate
over
6,000
streams
active@thismomentonfacebookliveatbloomberg.com
and munk debates stock calm.
It's great to have you as virtual
participants in tonight's proceedings
and hello to you the over 3000 people
who filled Roy Thomson Hall for yet
another monk debate.
Thank you for your support for more and
better debate on the big issues of the
day.
This debate marks the start of our 10th
season and we begin this season missing
someone who was vital to this debate
series in every aspect.
It was his passion for ideas,
his love for debate that inspired our
creation in 2008 and it was his energy,
his generosity,
and his drive that was so important in
allowing us to really win international
acclaim as one of the world's great
debating series,
his philanthropy,
it's legacy.
Wow.
It's incredible.
Last fall,
we all remember that hundred million
dollar donation to cardiac health.
Here in Toronto transforming the lives
of tens of thousands.
It's a million Canadians to come.
Rob,
we're all big fans and supporters of a
terrific school for global affairs on
the uft campus represented here tonight
by many students who are in its master's
program.
Congratulations
you
also in a generous endowment last spring
to this series that will allow us to
organize many evenings like this for
many more years to come now knowing our
benefactor as we,
uh,
the last thing he'd want is for us to
mark his absence with a moment of
silence.
That wasn't his style.
So let's instead celebrate a great
Canadian,
a great life,
and a great legacy of the late Peter
Munk Bravo Keytar
[inaudible].
I know he would have enjoyed that and I
want to just thank a Melanie Anthony
Chainy for being here tonight to be part
of Peter's continuing positive impact on
public debate in Canada.
Thank you guys
for being here tonight.
Now,
knowing Peter is,
I did the first thing on his mind at
this point in the debate would be right
here.
Stop talking.
Get this debate underway.
Get our debaters out here.
Come on,
you got to show on the road.
So we're going to do that right now
because we have a terrific debate lined
up for you this evening.
So let's introduce first our pro team
arguing for tonight's motion.
Be it resolved what you call political
correctness.
I call progress.
Please welcome to the stage.
He's an award winning writers,
scholar broadcaster on NPR and sports
networks across America.
Michael Eric Dyson.
Michael,
come on out.
[inaudible]
Michael's debating partner is also a
award winning author.
She's a columnist at the New York Times
and someone who is going to bring a very
distinct and powerful perspective
tonight.
Michelle Goldberg.
Michelle,
come on out.
[inaudible]
so one great team of debaters deserves
another and arguing against our
resolution,
be it resolved what you call political
correctness.
I call progress is the Emmy Award
winning actor,
screenwriter,
author,
playwright,
journalist,
poet,
and tonight and debater,
Stephen Fry.
[inaudible].
Stephen's teammates is a professor of
psychology at the University of Toronto,
a youtube sensation and the author of
the big new international bestseller,
12 rules for life.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Toronto's Jordan Peterson.
[inaudible].
Okay,
we're
going to get our debate underway
momentarily,
but first,
a quick checklist to go through it.
We've got a hashtag tonight hash at munk
debates.
Those of you in the hall and those of
you watching online,
please,
uh,
we in,
let's get your opinions going.
Also,
for those of you watching online right
now,
we haven't running pole a ww munk,
debates.com,
forward slash votes reflect input,
react to this debate as it unfolds over
the next hour and a half.
Uh,
my favorite part aspect of the show that
was Peter's a brilliance and creation.
We have our countdown clock.
What this does is it keeps our debaters
on their toes and our debate on time.
So when you see these clocks on the
screen,
go down to zero.
I wanted you to join me in a warm round
of applause and,
uh,
we'll have a debate that ends when it's
supposed to end.
Uh,
now,
let's see.
We had our resolution tonight on the way
in.
We have this audience of roughly 3000
people here in downtown Toronto vote on
be it resolved what you call political
correctness.
I call progress.
Let's see the agreed disagree on that
number.
36% agree.
64% disagree.
So a room and play.
Now we asked you how many of you are
open to changing your vote over the
course of the debate?
Are you fixed,
agree,
disagree,
or could you potentially be convinced by
one or other of these two teams to move
your vote over the next hour and a half?
Let's see those numbers now.
Wow.
Okay.
A pretty open minded crowd.
This debate is very much in play and as
per the agreed upon order of speakers,
I'm going to call him Michelle Goldberg
first.
Michelle,
would you like a sip of water?
Are you gonna have a sip of water?
Okay,
we're ready to start a column.
Michelle Goldberg first for her.
Six minutes of opening remarks.
Michelle,
thank you for having me.
And as regular notice,
I initially balked a little bit at the
resolution that we're debating because
there are a lot of things that fall
under the rubric of political
correctness that I don't call progress.
I don't like no platforming or twitter
or,
um,
trigger warnings.
Um,
you know,
like a lot of
middle age liberals,
there are many aspects of students'
social justice culture that I find off
putting,
although I'm not sure that that
particular generation gap is anything,
is anything new.
I'm on the record about the toxicity of
social media,
call out culture.
And I think it's good to debate people
whose ideas I don't like,
which is why I'm here.
Um,
so if there are social justice warriors
and the audience,
I feel like I should apologize to you
because I'm probably not,
you're probably gonna feel like I'm not
adequately defending your ideas.
Um,
but the reason I'm on this side of the
stage is that political correctness
isn't just a term for left wing excesses
on college campuses or people being
terrible on twitter especially is
deployed by Mr. Peterson.
I think it can be a way to deal,
legitimize any attempt for women and
racial and sexual minorities to overcome
discrimination or even to argue that
such discrimination is real.
Um,
in the New York Times today,
Mr. Peterson says,
quote,
the people who hold that aisle that our
culture isn't an oppressive patriarchy.
They don't want to admit that the
current hierarchy might be predicated on
competence.
That sounds particularly in scene to me
because I'm an American and our
president is Donald Trump.
But,
um,
but it's an assumption that I think
underlies a worldview in which any
challenges to the current hierarchy are
written off as political correctness.
I also think we should be clear that
this isn't really a debate about free
speech.
Um,
Mr. Peterson once referred to what he
called quote that evil trinity of
equity,
diversity and inclusivity and said those
three words,
if you hear people mouth those three
words,
equity,
diversity,
and inclusivity,
you know who you're dealing with and you
should step away from that because it is
not acceptable.
Um,
he argues that the movie frozen is
politically correct propaganda.
And at one point he floated the idea of
creating a database of university course
content so students could avoid
postmodern critical theory.
So in the criticism of political
correctness,
I sometimes hear an urge or an attempt
to purge our thought of certain
analytical categories that viewers,
I think the worst characatures of the
social justice left that want to get rid
of anything that smacks of colonialism
or patriarchy or white supremacy.
I also don't really think we're debating
the value of the enlightenment.
Um,
at least not in the way that somebody
like Mr. Frye.
I think as a champion of enlightenment
values springs,
it,
that Fritz to expand rights and
privileges once granted just to land
owning white heterosexual men is the
enlightenment or it's very much in
keeping with the enlightenment to quote
a dead white man,
John Stuart Mill,
the despotism of custom is everywhere,
the standing hindrance to human
advancement.
Um,
I think that some of our opponents by
contrast challenges to the despotism of
custom as politically correct attacks on
a transcendent natural order.
Um,
to quote Mr. Peterson again,
each gender,
each sex has its own and fairness to
deal with.
But to think of it as a consequence of
the shoulders of the social structure.
It's like,
come on,
really.
What about nature itself?
Um,
but there's an exception to this because
he does believe in social interventions
to remedy some kinds of unfairness,
which is why in the New York Times he
calls for quote enforced monogamy to
remedy the woes of men who don't get
their equal distribution of sex.
Um,
when it comes to the political
correctness debate,
we've been exactly here before the Alan
Blum,
the author of the closing of the
American mind compared the tyranny of
feminism in academia to the Khmer Rouge.
And he was writing at a time when women
accounted for 10% of all college tenured
faculty.
It's worth looking back at what was
considered annoyingly,
outrageously,
politically correct in the 1980s the
last time we had this debate,
you know,
having to call or not being able to call
indigenous people,
quote Indians are having to use
hyphenated terms,
at least in the United States of terms
like African Americans,
you know,
adding women or people of color to the
western Civ curriculum,
not making gay jokes or using retard is
an epithet.
And I kind of get it,
right,
new concepts,
new words,
sort of sticking your throat the way
we're used to talking and thinking seem
natural and normal,
you know,
by definition.
And then the new terms and new concepts
that have social utility stick and those
that don't fall away.
So if you go back to the 1970s,
ms,
you know,
ms as an alternative to miss or Mrs
stuck around and women with a y didn't.
Um,
and I think that some day I hope that
someday we'll look back and marvel at
the idea that gender neutral pronouns
ever seen like an existential threat to
anyone.
Um,
but I also don't think it's clear that,
you know,
that might not happen because if you
look around the world right now,
there are plenty of places that have
indeed dialed back cosmopolitanism and
reinstated patriarchy in the name of
staving off chaos and they seem like
terrible places to live.
Um,
you know,
I come to you from the United States,
which is currently undergoing a
monumental attempt to roll back social
progress in the name of overcoming
political correctness.
And as someone who lives there,
I assure you,
it feels nothing like progress.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
great.
Start to the debate Michelle.
Thank you.
I'm now going to ask Jordan Peterson to
speak for the con team.
Hello.
So we should first decide what we're
talking about.
We're not talking about my views of
political correctness despite what you
might have inferred from the last
speaker's comments.
This is how it looks to me.
We essentially need something
approximating a low resolution grant
narrative to unitus and,
and we did a narrative to is because
otherwise we don't have peace.
What's playing out in the universities
and in broader society right now is a
debate between two fundamental low
resolution narratives.
Neither of which can be completely
accurate because they can't encompass
all the details.
Obviously human beings have an
individual element and a collective
element,
a group element.
Let's say the question is what story
should be paramount?
And this is how it looks to me in the
west,
we have reasonably functional,
reasonably free,
remarkably productive,
stable hierarchies that are open to
consideration of the dispossessed that
hierarchies generally create.
Our societies are freer and functioning
more effectively than any societies,
anywhere else in the world.
And that,
and then any societies ever have.
And as far as I'm concerned,
and I think there's good reason to
assume this,
it's because the fundamental low
resolution,
uh,
grant narrative that we've oriented
ourselves around in the West is one of
the sovereignty of the individual.
And it's predicated on the idea that all
things considered the best way for me to
interact with someone else's individual
to individual and to react to that
person as if they're both part of the
process.
Because that's the right way of thinking
about it.
The psychological process by which
things we don't understand can yet be
explored and buy things that aren't
properly organized in our society can be
yet set.
Right.
And the reason we're valuable as
individuals,
both with regards to our rights and
responsibilities is because that's our
essential purpose.
And that's our nobility and that's our
function.
What's happening as far as I'm concerned
in the universities in particular,
and spreading very rapidly out into the
broader world,
including the corporate world,
much to it's much to what should be,
its chagrin is a collectivist narrative.
And of course there's some utility in a
collectivist narrative cause we're all a
part of groups in different ways.
But the collectivist narrative that I
regard as politically correct as a
pastiche of a strange pastiche of
postmodernism and neo Marxism and its
fundamental claim is that no,
you're not essentially an individual.
You're essentially a member of a group.
And that group might be your ethnicity
and it might be your sex and it might be
a race.
And it might be any of the endless
numbers of other potential groups that
you belong to because you belong to many
of them and that you should be
essentially categorized along with those
who are light cue on that dimension in
that group.
That's proposition number one.
Proposition number two is that the
proper way to view the world is as a
battle ground between groups of
different power so you define the groups
first and then you assume that you,
you you view the individual from the
group context.
You viewed the battle between groups
from the group context and you view
history itself as a consequence of
nothing but the power maneuvers between
different groups.
That eliminates any consideration of the
individual and at a very fundamental
level and also any idea for example of
free speech because if you're
collectivist at heart in this manner,
there is no such thing as free speech.
It isn't that it's debated by those on
the radical left and let's say the rest
of us so to speak.
It's that in that formulation there's no
such thing as free speech because for an
individualist,
free speech is how you make sense of the
world and reorganize society in a proper
manner.
But for the radical left type
collectivist,
it's associated with this viewpoint of
political correctness.
When you speak,
all you're doing is playing a power game
on behalf of your group and there's
nothing else that you can do because
that's all there is.
And not only is that all there is in
terms of who you are as an individual
now and how society should be viewed.
It's also the fundamental narrative of
history.
For example,
it's,
it's widely assumed in our universities
now that the best way to conceptualize
Western civilization is as an oppressive
male dominated patriarchy and that the
best way to construe relationships
between men and women across the
centuries is one of oppression of women
by men as like,
well,
look,
no hierarchy is without its tyranny.
That's a,
that's an axiomatic truth.
People have recognized that literally
for thousands of years and hierarchies
do tend towards tyranny and they tend
towards the usurpation by people with
power,
but that only happens when they become
corrupt and we have mechanisms in our
society to stop hierarchies from
becoming intolerable,
be corrupt,
and they actually work pretty well and
so and so.
I would also,
I would also point this out,
you know,
don't be thinking that this is a debate
about whether empathy is useful or not
or that the people on the con side of
the argument are not empathetic.
I know perfectly well as I'm as an sure
Mr. Fry does that.
Hierarchies tend to produce situations
where people stack up at the bottom and
that the dispossessed and hierarchies
need a political voice,
which is the proper voice of the left by
the way,
and the necessary voice of the left.
But that is not the same as proclaiming
that the right level of analysis for our
grand unifying narrative is that all of
us are fundamentally to be identified by
the groups that we belong to and to
construe the entire world as the
battleground between different forms of
tyranny in consequence of that group
affiliation.
And to the degree that we play out that
narrative,
that won't be progress.
Believe me.
And we certainly haven't seen that
progress in the universities.
We've seen situations like what happened
at Wilfrid laurier university had stead,
we won't see progress.
What will return to is exactly the same
kind of tribalism to characterize the
lab.
Thank you Jordan.
Uh,
Michael,
Eric Dyson.
Your six minutes starts now.
Thank you very kindly.
Wonderful opportunity to be here in
Canada.
Um,
well thank you so much.
I'm going to stand here at the podium.
I'm a preacher
and I will ask for an offering at the
end of my presentation.
This is the swimsuit competition of the
intellectual beauty pageant.
So let me show you the curves of my
thought.
Oh my God.
Was that a politically incorrect
statement I just made?
How did we get to the point where the
hijacking of the discourse on political
correctness has become a kind of magnet
keen distinction between us and them?
The abortive fantasy just presented is
remarkable for both its clarity and yet
the muddiness of the context from which
it has emerged.
What's interesting to me is that when we
look at the radical left,
I'm saying where he had,
I want to join them,
they ain't run enough,
and I'm from a country where a man
stands up everyday to tweet the moral
mendacity of his viciousness into a
nation.
He has turned into his psychic commode.
Y'All got justin,
we got Donald.
So what's interesting then is that
political correctness has transmogrified
into a caricature of the left.
The left came up with the term political
correctness.
Shell out reminds you,
we were tired of our excuses.
In our excesses in are exaggerations.
We were willing to be self critical in a
way that I fear my call friends.
My compatriots are not.
Don't take yourself too seriously.
Smile.
Take yourself not seriously at all,
but what you do with deadly seriousness.
Now it is transmogrified into an attempt
to characterize the radical left.
The radical left is a metaphor as a
symbol,
as an articulation.
They don't exist.
They're numbers are too small.
I'm on college campuses.
I don't see much of them coming.
When I hear about identity politics,
that amazes me.
The collectivist identity politics.
Uh,
last time I checked,
white folk invented race.
That was an invention from a dominant
culture that won't it groups to at their
behest,
the invention of race was driven by the
demand of a dominant culture to
subordinate others.
Patriot,
right?
Patriarchy.
Patriarchy was the demand of men to have
their exclusive vision presented.
The beauty of feminism is it's not going
to resolve differences between men and
women.
It just says me,
I don't automatically get the last word
of course,
of my career,
but he never did.
And so identity politics has been
generated as a bit in the war of the
right,
and yet the right doesn't understand the
degree to which identity has been
foisted upon black people and Brown
people and people of color from the very
beginning on women and Trans People.
You think that I want to be part of a
group that is constantly at poured by
people at starbucks.
I'm minding my own black business
walking down the street.
I have group identity thrust upon me.
They don't say,
ah,
there goes a Negro,
highly intelligent,
articulate,
verbose,
capable of rhetorical fury at the drop
of a hat.
We should not interrogate him as to the
bone of the days of his legal status.
No,
they treat me as part of a group and the
problem is that our friends don't want
to acknowledge is that the had Gemini,
that dominance of that group has been so
vicious that it is denied us the
opportunity to exist as individuals.
Individualism is the characteristic
moment in modernity.
Mr. Peterson is right,
the development of the individual.
However,
it's predicated upon notions of
intelligence in mind.
You will content David,
human,
others philosophically cart descartes
comes along introducing knowledge into
the,
to the,
to the phrase saying that knowledge is
based upon a kind of reference to the
golden intelligence,
the reflective glass at one possesses.
And yet he got rooted in the very ground
of our existence.
So now it's has fleshly basis.
And what I'm saying to you,
the knowledge that I bring as a person
of color makes a difference in my body.
Because I know what people think of me
and I know how they respond to me.
And that ain't no theory am I.
Am I mad at trigger warnings?
Only trigger warning.
Got One is from a cop.
Are you about to shoot me?
Not Funny.
In America where young black people die
repeatedly,
unarmed without provocation.
And so for me,
identity politics is something very
serious.
And what's interesting about safe
spaces,
I hear about the university,
I teach there.
Look,
if you in a safe space in your body,
you don't need a safe space.
Some of that is overblown,
some of it is ridiculous.
I understand.
I believe that the classroom was a
robust place for serious learning.
I believe in the interrogation of
knowledge,
based upon our understanding of mutually
of the edifying proposition of enlighten
met.
At the same time,
some people ain't as equal as others.
So we have to understand the conditions
under which they have emerged and in
which they have been benighted.
And attacked by their own culture and I
ain't seen nobody be a biggest snowflake
in and white man who complained,
mommy,
they won't let us play and have
everything we used to have under the old
regime where we were right.
Racist and some premises and dominate
and patriarchs and hated gays and
lesbians and transsexuals that,
yeah,
you got to share.
This ain't Joe World.
There's everybody's world.
And let me end by saying this.
You remember that story from David
Foster Wallace?
Fish are going down to fish are gone and
the older fish comes in the opposite
direction.
He said,
hello boys.
How's the water they swim on?
They turn each other.
What the Hell is water?
Because when you entered,
you don't know it.
When you're dominant,
Nothing.
Keyser soze he said it's more
interesting,
but the devil did.
And to make people believe he did
exist.
That's what you [inaudible].
Thank you Michael.
Steven Europe.
Oh,
we're going to put six minutes on the
clock and please start out trying to be
as quick as possible because if I miss
that plane to London,
I went half here,
the end of it from the bridegroom's
mother.
Um,
now in,
in agreeing to,
uh,
participate in this debate and stand on
this side of the argument,
I'm fairly aware that many people who
choose incorrectly in my view to,
to see this issue in terms of left and
right,
devalued and exploded terms as I think
they are,
will believe that I am betraying myself
in such causes and values that I have
espoused over the years.
I've been given a huge grief or red.
It seemed to because I'm standing here
next to Professor Peterson,
which is the very reason that I am
standing here in the first place.
I'm standing next to someone with whom I
have no differences,
shall we say in terms of politics and
all kinds of other things.
Um,
precisely because I think all this has
got to stop this rage,
resentment,
hostility,
hostility in tolerance above all this
with us or against us.
Certainty.
A Grand Canyon has opened up in our
world.
The fist year,
the crack grows wider.
Every day.
Neither on each side can hear a word
that the other shrieks and nor do they
want to.
One of these arm isn't propagandist in
the culture wars clash down below in the
enormous space between the two sides.
The people of the world tried to get on
with their lives.
Alternative baffled board and betrayed
by the horrible noises and explosions
that echo all around.
I think it's time for this toxic binary.
Zero.
Some madness to stop before we destroy
ourselves.
Okay.
The nail my colors to the mast,
uh,
before I go any further than this,
it's only polite to give you a sense of
where I come from.
I all my adult life,
I have been what you might call the left
here,
a soft lefty liberal of the most
handwringing milk shop,
milk,
toast,
variety,
not to burning man.
The barricades socialist,
not even really a progressive with the
name.
I've been on marches,
I've never quite dead.
We've clicked cards or banners.
Um,
am I alluded member of that band,
an Sjw,
a social justice warrior.
I don't think highly of social
injustice,
I have to say,
but I character myself mostly as a
social justice warrior.
My intellectual heroes growing up were
Bertrand Russell and g more liberal
thinkers,
people like that.
Writers like m forced to,
I believed in,
I think I still do believe in the
sanctity of human relations,
of the primacy of the heart and
friendship and love and common interest.
These are more personal interior beliefs
than they are political exterior
convictions,
more humanistic version of a religious
implants.
I suppose.
I trust in humanity.
I believe in humanity.
I think I do.
Despite all that has happened in the 40
years of my adulthood,
I am soft and I can easily be swept away
by harder hearts and harder intellect.
I'm sometimes surprised to be described
as an activist,
but overtime I have energetically
involved myself with what you might call
causes.
I grew up knowing that I was gay.
Well,
in fact,
from the very first I knew I was gay.
I remember when I was born looking up
and saying,
that's the last time I'm going up.
One of those.
I'm,
I'm
Jewish,
I'm Jewish,
so I have a natural,
I was horror of racism.
Um,
I naturally,
I want racism,
misogyny,
homophobia,
transphobia,
xenophobia,
bullying,
bigotry,
intolerance of all humankind's to end
that surely a given amongst all of us.
The question is how such a golden aim is
to be achieved.
My ultimate objection to political
correctness is not that it combines so
much of what I've spent a lifetime
losing and opposing preachiness with
great respect.
Um,
piety,
self-righteousness Harris,
he hunting denunciation shaming session
without evidence,
accusation,
inquisition censoring.
That's not why I'm incurring the wrath
of my fellow liberals by standing on
this side of the house.
My real objection is that I don't think
political correctness works.
I want to achieve,
I want to get to the Golden Hill,
but I don't think that's the way to get
there.
Um,
I believe one of the greatest human
failings is to prefer to be right,
than to be effective.
Um,
political correctness.
He's always obsessed with how right it
is without thinking of how effective it
might be.
I wouldn't trust myself as a classical
libertarian,
uh,
but I do relish transgression and I
deeply and instinctively distrust
conformity and orthodoxy.
Progress is not by preachers and
guardians of morality bumped to
paraphrase,
you have [inaudible] by madmen hermits,
heretics,
dreamers,
rebels and skeptics.
I,
uh,
I may be wrong.
I hope to learn this evening.
I really do think I may be wrong,
but I am prepared to entertain the
possibility that political correctness
will bring us more tolerance and a
better world.
Um,
but I'm not sure and I would like this
quotation from my hair,
a Bertrand Russell to hover over the
evening.
One of the painful things about our time
is that those who feel certainty are
stupid and those with any imagination
and understanding are filled with doubt
and indecision.
Doc [inaudible],
great set of,
uh,
opening statements to set the scene.
We're now going to go into a round of
rebuttals to allow each of our
presenters three minutes to reflect on
what they've heard and to make some
additional points.
And we're going to do that in the same
order that we had.
The opening statement.
So Michelle,
you're up first.
We'll put three minutes on the clock for
you.
So first I would say that I think that
the attempt to draw a dichotomy between
individual rights and group rights is a
little bit misleading.
Um,
traditionally there has been large
groups of people who have not been able
to exercise their individual rights.
And I think that a lot of the claims
that are being made on behalf of what we
politically correct types call
marginalized groups are claims that
people who have identities that have not
traditionally been at the center of our
culture or been at the top of our
hierarchies have as much right to
exercise their individual talents and
realize their individual ambitions.
Right.
When we say that we want more women in
power or more people of color's voices
in the Canon or in the curriculum,
or you know,
pete directing movies,
all of these things or not,
because at least on my part,
I'm interested in some sort of very
crude equity,
but because there are a lot of people
who have not traditionally been able to
realize themselves as individuals.
That's what the women's movement was.
That's what the civil rights movement
was.
That's what the gay rights movement was.
That's in some ways what the Trans
Rights movement was.
I mean,
far from a collectivist movement.
This is kind of liberalism,
classical liberalism pushed to its
extreme,
right?
These are people saying,
I have the right to define my identity
against the one that was collectively
assigned to me.
Um,
finally I would say,
you know,
a lot of the things that Stephen Fry
said,
you know,
in particularly his temperament,
we're probably in agreement,
but this inquisition,
this censorious snus.
On the one hand,
I'm sort of,
I see where he's coming from,
but I think it's a little bit virtual,
right?
I mean,
no,
but who's,
who's really censoring you?
Um,
I understand what it feels like to feel
censored.
I understand what it feels like to be on
the wrong side of a twitter mob or get a
lot of nasty comments,
but,
and that's a bad feeling,
you know,
and it's a counterproductive tactic,
but that's not censorship.
Um,
you know,
and again,
it's a little,
it's especially strange coming from a
country where,
you know,
the president of the United States is
trying to levy additional postal rates
on the owner of the Washington Post,
you know,
in revenge for its reporting.
And people who have kneeled to protest
police brutality at football games have
seen their careers explode.
You know,
or people who have,
you know,
women who have challenged Mr. Peterson
has been hounded by threats and trolls
and misogynist.
Um,
invective so
[inaudible] Jordan,
three minutes up on the screen there.
Please respond to what you've heard.
Well,
I guess I would like to set out a
challenge in,
in somewhat the same format as Mr. Fry
did two people on the moderate left.
I mean,
I've studied totalitarianism for a very
long time.
Both on the left and on the right.
They have various forms and
I think we've done a pretty decent job
of determining when right wing beliefs
become dangerous.
I think that they become dangerous when
they,
the people who stand on the right evoke
notions of racial superior superiority
or ethnic superiority,
something like that.
It's fairly easy to draw a box around
them and place them to one side and
necessary.
And I think we've done a pretty good job
of that.
What I failed to see happening on the
left,
and this is with regards to the sensible
left because such a thing exists,
is for the same thing to happen with
regards to the radical leftists.
Okay,
so here's an open question.
If it's not diversity,
inclusivity and equity as a triumvirate
that mark out the two excessive left and
with equity defined by the way,
not as equality of opportunity,
which is an absolutely laudable goal,
but as equality of outcome,
which is how it's defined then exactly
how do we demarcate the two extreme
left?
What did we do?
And we say,
well,
there's no such thing as the two extreme
left.
Well,
that's certainly that characterize much
of intellectual thinking for the 20th
century as our high order intellectuals,
especially in place like places like
France did,
everything they could to bend over
backwards to ignore absolutely
everything that was happening in the
catastrophic left world in the Soviet
Union and in Maoist China not least.
We've done a terrible job of determining
how to demarcate what's useful from the
left,
from what's pathological.
And so it's perfectly okay for someone
to criticize my attempts to identify
something like a boundary.
We could say diversity,
inclusivity and equity,
especially equity,
which is in fact equality of outcome,
which is an absolutely a boring notion.
If you know anything about history,
you know that and I'm perfectly willing
to hear some reasonable alternatives.
But what I hear continually from people
on the left,
first of all,
as my opponent's did to construe every
argument that is possibly able to be
construed on the axis of group
identification and to fail,
to defer,
to,
to fail,
to help the rest of us differentiate the
reasonable left,
which stands for the oppressed
necessarily from the pathological left.
It's capable of unbelievable
destruction.
And what I see happening in the
university campuses in particular where
the left is absolutely predominate and
that's certainly not my imagination.
That's that's well documented by
perfectly reasonable people like
Jonathan.
Height is an absolute failure to make
precisely that distinction and I see the
same thing tonight.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
oh,
give us a,
your rebuttal.
Let me step out here and Peterson land.
Oh,
I feel free.
You're already,
I don't know what mythological
collective Mr. Peterson refers to.
I'm part of the left there.
Can tankers when they have a firing
squad is usually in a semi circle.
Part of the skepticism of rationality
was predicated upon the enlightenment
project,
which says we're no longer going to be
subordinate to skepticism to
superstition.
We're going to think and we're going to
think,
well,
Thomas Jefferson was one of the great
arbiters of rationality,
but he was also a man who was a slave
owner.
How do you reconcile that?
That's the complication I'm speaking
about.
That's not either or.
That's not a collective identity.
Thomas Jefferson believed in a
collective identity.
That is during the day at night,
he got some luther vandross songs,
went out to the slave quarter and
engaged in sexual relations and had many
children with sally hemings.
His loins trumped his logic and when he
hit talks about postmodernism,
I don't know who he's talking about.
I teach postmodernism.
It's kind of fun.
Jacques Derrida,
just to say his name is beautiful.
Michelle Michel Foucault talks about the
insurrection of subjugated knowledge as
people who had been marginalized.
Now begin to speak.
The subaltern has gaietry.
Speeback talks about it and post
postcolonial theory.
The reason these people grew up and grew
into existence and had a voice is
because they were denied.
As Ms Goldberg said,
our group identity was foisted upon us.
We were not seen as individuals.
Babe Ruth,
when he broke the home row home run
record,
he didn't bat against all best
ballplayers.
He batted against the best white
When it's been rigged in your favor from
the very beginning,
it's hard for you to understand how much
you've been rick.
You're born on third base.
Think you hit a triple
at the Toronto Blue Jays game.
And here we are deriving our sense of
identity from the very culture that we
ignore.
Look at the indigenous names and the
first nation names,
Toronto,
Saskatchewan,
when a peg Tim Horton's.
Okay.
But I'll tell you,
there's an envy of the kind of freedom
and liberty that people of color and
other minorities bring because we bring
the depth of knowledge in our body.
There's a kind of jealousy event as the
greatest living Canadian philosopher
Aubrey Drake Graham says,
jealousy is just love and hate at the
same time.
And so for me,
I think it's necessary.
I agree with Mr. Fry.
We shouldn't be nasty and combative and
yet I don't see nastiness and
combativeness from people.
I see them making a desire to have their
individual identities respected when I
get shot down for no other reason that
I'm black,
when I get categorized for no other
reason than my color,
I am living in a culture that refuses to
see me as a great individual.
Yeah.
It's interesting to hear that there
doesn't seem to be a problem,
but yet I think we all instinctively
know that there is some kind of problem.
There isn't censorship,
of course.
Not In the way that there is in Russia.
I've been to Russia,
faced off with the,
uh,
a deeply homophobic,
done pleasant man.
And there's political correctness in
Russia.
It's just political correctness on the
right.
And that's what I grew up with.
Political correctness,
which meant that you couldn't say
certain things on television.
You couldn't say fuck for example,
on television because it was incorrect
to do so.
And there's always the same reason was
that someone would appear and say,
I'm not shocked.
Oh,
of course.
No,
I'm not shocked.
I'm not offended.
I'm offended on behalf of others.
Young,
impressionable plastic mines,
the vulnerable.
And that's not good enough.
It's,
it's,
so often people are saying,
see,
I don't mind being called a faggot or a
cake or whatever,
or a mad person cause I've got mental
health issues.
I don't mind people insulting me and
people say,
what's that?
So right for you,
Steven,
because you're new,
you're strong.
I don't feel particularly strong and I
don't know that I like being called a
faggot and a cake particularly,
but I don't believe that the advances in
my culture that have allowed me to marry
as I have now been for three years to
someone of my gender,
I don't believe they are a result of
political correctness and maybe
political correctness is actually does
some sort of live trout that the harder
we squeeze it,
the further it goes away and,
and you will be saying,
I'm not talking about the redness,
you're talking about social justice with
which I agree with where they want to
call it identity politics or the history
of your people.
In the history of my people,
my people were slaves as well.
Both the British were slaves and Romans
and the Jews were slaves to the
Egyptians.
All human beings have been slaves at
some point and we all in that sense
share that knowledge of how important it
is to speak up.
But Russell means,
who was a friend of mine,
who was the end who founded the American
Indian movement.
He said,
oh,
I forgot to call me an Indian or a
Lakota Sioux or Russell,
I don't care what you call me.
It's how we treated that matters.
And so I'm really addressing a more
popular idea.
MMM.
Also actually in Barrow,
Alaska and the new Piet said,
call me an Eskimo.
It's obviously easier for you cause you
keep mispronouncing Inupiaq.
Um,
in a words do matter.
I'll just end with a quick story.
Uh,
gay rights came back to the England
because we just slowly in persistently
knocked on the door of people in power.
We didn't shout,
we didn't scream.
People like Ian mckellen eventually got
to see the prime minister.
And when the Queen signed in the royal
assent to she has to foot the bill
allowing equality of marriage.
She said,
Lord,
you know,
I couldn't imagine this in 1953 really
is extraordinary.
Isn't it?
Just wonderful and handed it over.
Now it's a nice story and I hope it's
true,
but it's nothing to do with political
correctness.
It's to do with human decency.
It's that simple.
[inaudible] great rebuttals.
They're strong opening statements.
Let's move now into the,
uh,
the moderated a cross examination
portion of this debate and get both
sides engaging on,
uh,
some of the key issues here.
And I think what we've heard here is a
bit of a attention.
Let's draw it out a bit more between uh,
the rights of groups to feel included,
to have in your words,
Michelle,
the opportunity for individuality and a
belief on the other side that uh,
there's something that's threat here
when these groups are overly privileged
through affirmative action or other
outcome oriented processes.
So Michael,
to start with you,
why,
why isn't there just harm that's done to
groups by privileging their group
identity,
whether it be a group identity of race
or of gender and not immediately
treating them as and the way that
Jordan and Steven would like to see you
see them first?
Well,
a couple of things.
First of all,
there was no arbitrary and random
distinction that people of color and
other minority groups made.
When I talked about the invention of
race,
the invention of gender,
the invention of group think that was
not done at the by.
Those groups that have been so named as
Miss Goldberg said.
So first of all,
you've got to acknowledge the historical
evolution of that reality and the
concept of group identity did not begin
with them.
It began with a group that didn't have
to announce its identity.
When you are in control,
you don't have to announce who you are
so that many white brothers and sisters
don't see themselves as one among many
other ethnicities or groups.
What they see themselves as,
I'm just American,
I'm Canadian,
can't you be like us?
Can't you transcend those narrow group
identifications and yet those group
identifications have been imprinted upon
them by the very people who now because
their,
their group power has been challenged.
Let's make no mistake about it.
There is a challenge.
I agree with Mr. Fry in a kind of
Netherland of how sweet it would be to
have a kingly and queen cleanly a
metaphor about how it got resolved.
That ain't the real deal,
homie.
And in the real world and in the real
world,
there's stuff at stake.
What's at stake?
Our bodies,
what's at stake or people's lives,
what's at stake?
People are still being lynched,
killed what's at stake.
People because of their sexuality and
their racial identity are still being
harmed.
So I'm suggesting to you,
it's not that we are against being
treated as individuals.
That's what we're crying for.
Please don't see me as a member of a
group that you think is a thug,
a nigger,
uh,
a nihilist,
a pathological person.
See me as an individual who embodies the
realities were on.
But I'll end by saying this.
What Michelle said is extremely
important.
The people who have individual rights,
it didn't have to fight for them in the
same manner that people of color and
others have had to.
When Mr Fried talked about getting slave
man,
he named them read Orlando Patterson's
comparative history of Race and slavery
over 28 civilizations.
The Greeks did not have the same kind of
slavery,
not American said it was chattel slavery
in Greece.
You could buy back your,
your your freedom.
You could teach the children of the
people who are enslaved you and because
of your display of prodigious intellect,
you could secure your freedom.
That was not the case.
You were punished and killed for
literacy in America.
So my point simply is this,
is that I am all for the celebration of
broader identities and I think that
often those who are minorities and
others are not celebrated for the degree
that we are.
I'll end by saying this.
In America we have the confederate flag.
I don't know if y'all are familiar with
that.
We have a confederate flag.
We have white guys mostly in the south,
but others as well flying those
confederate flags that are part of the
south that refuse to seed.
It's legitimate.
A conquest at the hands of the,
there has been a politics of resentment.
Every you talking about politics of
identity wearing that flag,
not the American flag.
They are not American.
They are celebrating us.
The session a move away from America and
a man named Colin Kaepernick who was a
football player saying I want to bring
beauty to that flag has been denied
opportunities.
So we have to really set the terms of
debate in order before we,
we proceed.
Thank you man.
Jordan,
let's have you jumped in on this idea of
what you see as the pernicious danger of
group think when it comes to ethnicity,
uh,
when it comes to gender.
Why do you think that that's one of the
primal sins in your view of,
of quote political correctness?
Well,
I think it's one of the primal sense of
identity politics players on the left
and the right.
Just to be clear about that personally,
since this has got personal at times,
I'm no fan of the identitarian right.
I think that anybody who plays a game,
uh,
conceptual game where group identity
comes first and foremost risks and
exacerbation of tribalism,
it doesn't matter whether it's on the
left to the right.
Um,
with regards to the idea of group
rights?
Well,
there's a fundamental,
and this is something we fall into
terribly in Canada,
not least because we had to contend with
the threat of Quebec separatism,
but the,
the idea of group writes is
extraordinarily problematic because the,
the,
the OBC verse of the coin of individual
rights is individual responsibilities
can,
you can hold an individual responsible
and an individual can be responsible.
And so that's partly why individuals
have rights,
but groups,
how do you hold a group responsible?
I mean,
the whole idea is not,
it's not a good idea to hold a group
responsible if,
first of all,
it flies in the face of the idea of the
sort of justice systems that we've laid
out in the West that are essentially
predicated first on the assumption of
individual innocence,
but also on the possibility of
individual guilt,
not group guilt.
We saw what happened in the 20th century
many,
many times when the idea of group guilt
was he was,
it was enabled to get a foothold,
let's say in the polity and in the
justice system.
It was absolutely catastrophic.
And so,
okay,
fine group rights.
Well what are you going,
how are you going to contend with the
alternative to that?
The opposite of that or where's the
group responsibility?
How are we going to keep,
how are we going to hold your group's
responsible?
Well,
we don't have to talk about that because
we're too concerned with rectifying
hypothetical rec rectifying historical
injustices,
hypothetical and otherwise.
And that's certainly not to say that
there weren't any shortage of absolutely
catastrophic historical injustices.
That's not the point.
The point is how you view the situation
at the most fundamental level and group
rights are absolute catastrophe in my
opinion.
Come on,
let's let Michelle come in on that.
Is this something you've written about?
The idea that you know,
in identity politics,
uh,
the,
the identity of the group is absolutely
a valid part of the discourse and,
and individuals could and should be seen
and participate in groups as they enter
into the civic space.
I'm not sure sure
that we necessarily have to analogize
from individual.
The,
you know,
the opposite of individual rights is
individual responsibility.
I'm not sure that that analogy
necessarily holds for the groups,
I mean,
in,
in the United States.
And one of the things that I think is
complicated about this discussion is
that we're talking about three very
different cultural context,
three different histories,
three different kind of legal regimes.
But in the United States,
um,
a great,
a huge part of our politics has been
groups struggling for rights for their
individual members.
Right?
I mean,
so women in the United States,
you know,
seeking the right to reproductive
control of their body.
Um,
you know,
African Americans in the United States
seeking redress from police brutality or
discrimination or simply the kind of
tendency in America of white people to
call the police whenever they see an
African American in a place where they
don't think that they're supposed to be.
And you simply,
I don't see how you can contend with any
of those social problems if you see
society as just an ocean of atomized
individuals.
Um,
you know,
and I just,
I again,
I,
I don't,
I don't think there's anything
pernicious about people banding together
on the basis of their common identity to
seek redress for discrimination and
exclusion.
I mean,
I think that that is everything that's
best about our democracy.
That is the definition of progress.
And so again,
I just,
I keep stumbling with the idea that this
is somehow tyrannical or that way lies
stolen ism.
Um,
and you know,
a lot of times people who are opposed to
political correctness talk about the
concept of category creep or is it,
no,
no.
Um,
yeah,
category creek,
which is a concept that was originated
by,
I believe in Australian academic,
and it's basically kind of a failure to
draw distinctions,
right?
So that you kind of can't see the
difference between say a KKK grand
wizard and a conservative like say Ben
Shapiro or you know,
that you kind of see everybody to your
right,
as you know,
fascist,
sexist to tall rotarian and tolerable.
And I think that that is a real thing
that happens in part because,
you know,
undergraduates often thinking broad and
slightly overwrought categories.
I know I did when I was,
when I was a kid.
Um,
yeah,
maybe still do,
but,
but I,
I hear a lot of category creep in again,
the argument against political
correctness or against seeking group
readdress the idea that kind of that way
lies to humanization or you know,
that you're kind of one minute
what's up steven,
come in on this part of your opening
remarks.
Your,
you're a category creeps.
Steven didn't respond to that.
It's a nice,
I'm,
I'm still very lost about why we aren't
talking about political correctness.
We're talking about politics and uh,
ah,
that's fine.
Uh,
you know,
share exactly what you think about it.
I'm not an enemy of identity politics
per se.
I can obviously see where it goes wrong
and where it's annoying.
Let's be empirical about this.
How well is it working for you in
America at the moment?
Well,
not well at all.
Really isn't,
you can ask me in a moment.
Um,
the reason,
the reason that trump and brexit in
Britain and all kinds of nativist all
over Europe and succeeding is not the
time for the right.
It's the catastrophic failure of the
left.
It's our fault.
My point is not
did I've turned to the right or anything
like that.
All that I'm nice and fluffy and want
everybody to be decent.
I'm saying,
fuck political correctness,
resist fight.
If you have a point of view,
fight it in the proper manner using
democracy as it should be.
Not Channel
Love,
education,
not language.
You know,
it's so silly,
but
you think that there's a chess rule.
You know,
in chess,
the best move to playing chess is not
the best chess move.
It's the move your opponent least wants
you to play.
At the moment you're being recruiting
sergeants for the right,
knowing an upsetting,
and instead of fighting,
either fighting or persuading.
But political correctness is a middle
course that simply doesn't work well.
First of all,
please,
you said be empirical.
Empirical,
as far as I know,
the word means that which can be
verified if falsify through the
sentence.
Exactly.
So if we look at it in an objective a
way,
uh,
the,
the reality is that people don't have
equal access to the means to articulate
the very moment you're talking about,
I'm talking about the empirical results
of this political attitudes.
I understand that,
but my point is simply this,
I'm suggesting to you that people use
the weapons at hand.
Now it was Abraham Joshua Heschel,
rabbi who said,
everybody's not guilty,
but everybody's responsible,
right?
That's a distinction there.
Everybody clearly is not guilty.
But what's interesting,
and look at the flip side,
if you have benefited from 300 years of
holding people in servitude thinking
that you did it all on your own,
why can't these people work harder?
And let me see you for 300 years you
ain't had no job.
So the reality is for 300 years,
you old people in the bands,
you hold them in subordination,
you refuse to give them rights.
Then all of a sudden you free them and
say you're now individuals not having
the skills,
the skills optimized America.
First of all,
I'm talking of the American society.
I'm talking about the northern
hemisphere.
I'm talking about every society where
enslavement has existed,
but I'm speaking specifically of the
repudiation of individual rights among
people of Color in America who were
denied the opportunity to be
individuals.
So I see,
I obviously an ideal we'd,
I think Michelle Goldberg does to agree
with the emphasis on individuals.
What we're saying to you is that we have
not been permitted to be individuals.
We have not been permitted to exercise
our individual autonomy and authority
and the refusal to do so.
To recognize me as an individual means
when you roll up on me and I'm a 12 year
old boy in a park and you shoot first in
ways you do the black kids that you
don't do the white kids,
you are not treating that person as an
individual.
If we're living in a society where women
are subject to aberrant forms of horrid
to patriarchal,
sexist and misogynist behavior,
you are not acknowledging the centrality
of the individuality of women.
You are treating them according to eight
group dynamic.
And if we,
if we get beyond the ability of people
on the right to understand the degree to
which they have operated from the basis
of benefit from group identity,
without having to say like by saying
this,
the great American philosopher beyond
say nose
say it,
that it has been said that racism is so
American that if you challenge racism,
you look like you're challenging
America.
We are challenging inequality.
We are challenging the refusal to see me
as an individual when we overcome that
have added,
we're all on here.
Three items getting stirred here.
A couple of questions.
So let's let your sites folks are going
to go to Jordan then to you.
Let's just assume for a moment that I've
benefited from my white privilege.
Okay.
So let's assume that that's fine.
Yeah,
well that's what you would say.
So,
um,
uh,
so let
here,
let's get precise this,
okay.
Was that in the very individual of you?
Let's get precise about this.
Okay.
He's good.
Precise
degree.
Is My preference present level of
attainment or achievement?
A consequence of my white privilege.
And I don't mean sort of,
I mean do you mean 5% do you mean 15% do
you mean 25% do you mean 75% and what do
you propose I do about it?
How about a tax?
How about a tax that's like specialized
for me so that I can account for my damn
privilege.
You,
you read about it?
No,
let's get precise about one other thing.
Okay.
We'll get precise
about one other thing.
There's sites.
Yeah,
precise.
Yes.
And so if,
if we can agree and we haven't,
that the left can go too far,
which it clearly camp,
then how would my worthy opponents
precisely defined when the left that
they stand for has gone too far?
You didn't like equity,
equality of outcome.
I think that's a great marker.
But if you have a better suggestion and
won't sidestep the question.
So let's figure out how I can dispense
with my white privilege.
And so that you can tell me
when the left has gone too far since
they clearly can.
And that's what this debate is about,
about political correctness.
It's about the left going too far.
And I think it's gone too far in many
ways.
And I'd like to figure out exactly how
and when.
So the reasonable left could make it's a
sentence again and we could quit all
this nonsense.
Okay.
I will answer you,
but I just want to answer Steven Fry
first because you talked about,
you know,
this is how we got trump and this is the
failure of the left.
And so I,
you know,
I'm a journalist.
I went to a ton of trump rallies during
the campaign in different parts of the
country.
And you're right,
everywhere I went,
I heard complaints about political
correctness,
you know,
far more than I heard complaints about
say Nafta.
Um,
but when you asked people what they
meant by political correctness,
you know,
they call it a woman.
They worked with girl and she got mad at
them and you know,
they could,
you know,
you couldn't in public wonder aloud
whether the president of the United
States was really a Muslim.
Um,
you know,
they didn't like that they couldn't make
gay jokes anymore.
And so on the one hand,
you're right and I've written about
this,
I think that when you try to,
um,
support,
you know that when people have these
prejudices and you try to suppress them,
it can create a kind of dangerous
counter reaction.
But I also think that,
you know,
what they were reacting to,
again to go,
to go back to the title of this debate,
what they called political correctness.
You know,
the fact that they had to have this
urbain black president who they felt
talked down to that which is really what
they meant.
Um,
I don't see a way around that because
that is,
like I said,
that's progress.
Um,
so to go to the,
to the question of when the left goes
too far,
I mean to me it's pretty easy violence
and censorship against violence and I'm
against censorship.
But I also looking around the world
right now when the idea that there is
this,
I understand again,
there is like a problem of kind of left
wing annoyance,
right?
There's a lot of things that kind of
people,
random people on the internet in
particular are able to swarm individuals
and turn kind of stray remarks and just
social media campaigns.
And this is often conflated with
political correctness and it's a bad
phenomenon.
I wish there was a way to put an end to
it.
I don't think there,
there is no way to put an end to it
simply by having kind of reasonable
liberals are reasonable.
Socialists denounce it because it's just
a kind of awful phenomenon of modern
life.
And if you want to have a debate about
whether social media is terrible for
democracy,
I will be on the gay side.
Um,
but right now where I really disagree.
Well a couple of,
there's a couple of,
I really disagree but I'm going to go to
Michael,
but the idea that the radical left poses
a greater threat than the radical right.
When you see fat,
like actual fascism ascendant all over
the world strikes me as something that
you can literally only believe if you
spend your life on college campuses.
Mike,
I want to come to you on those.
Pregnant Shaw on Jordan's point about
how does he in a sense get an equal
voice in this debate back if it is
implied that his participation brings
with it this baggage of white privilege
that doesn't allow him to see clearly
the issues that are before us.
But that is to be complicit in the very
problem that self terminal.
Logically you're beginning at a point
this,
there's already a productive and
controversial.
You're saying how can he get his
equality?
Beck who you talking about?
Jordan Peterson trending number one on
twitter.
Jordan Peterson international
bestseller.
I want him to tweet something out about
me and my book Jordan Peterson,
right?
This is what I'm saying to you,
why the rage,
Bruh?
You you,
you're doing well but your amine mad
white man and you're going to get us
right and
I have never seen so much line and snow
flaking.
There's enough light in here to start a
vineyard.
And what I'm saying to you empirically
and precisely when you asked the
question about white privilege,
the fact that you ask it and the way you
did dismissive pseudoscientific,
non empirical and without justification
a,
the truth is that white privilege
doesn't act according to a quantifiable
segments.
It's about the degree to which we are
willing as a society to grapple with the
ideals of treat them justice and
equality upon which is base number two
was interesting to me.
You're talking about not having a
collective identity.
What do you call a nation?
Are you Canadian?
Are you Canadian by yourself?
Are you an individual or are you part of
a group?
When America have formed it's union,
it did so in opposition to another
group,
so the reality is is that those who are
part of group identities and politics
denied the legitimacy and validity of
those groups and the fact that they have
been created thusly and ben have
resentment against others.
All I'm asking for is the opportunity
that this the quotation you talk about
the difference between quality of
outcome and equality of opportunity.
That's a state and retried argument.
Hackneyed phrase derived from the
halcyon days of the debate over
affirmative action.
Are you looking for outcomes that can be
determined equally or are you looking
for opportunity?
If you free a person after a whole long
time of oppression and say,
now you are free to survive if you have
no skills,
if you have no quantifiable means of
existence,
what you have done is liberated them
into,
and all I'm suggesting to you,
Lyndon Baines Johnson,
one of our great presidents said,
if you start a man in a race a hundred
years behind,
it is awfully difficult to catch up.
So I don't think Jordan Peterson is
suffering from anything except an
exaggerated sense of entitlement and
resentment and his own privilege is
invisible to him and it's manifest with
lethal intensity and ferocity right
here.
All state
Jordan,
you respond to that?
Well,
what I derived from that series of
rebuttals,
let's say is two fold.
The first is that saying that the
radical left goes too far when they
engage in violence is not a sufficient
response by any stretch of the
imagination because there are sets of
ideas in radical leftist thinking that
led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century,
and that was at the level of idea,
not at the level of violent action.
It's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against the violence.
It's like being against poverty.
It's like,
you know,
gender,
generically speaking,
decent people are against poverty and
violence.
It doesn't address the issue in the
least.
Um,
and with regards to my privilege or lack
thereof,
I mean,
I'm not making the case that I haven't
had advantages in my life and
disadvantages in my life.
Like most people,
you don't know anything about my
background and where it came from.
It,
it doesn't matter to you because
fundamentally I'm a mean white man.
That's a hell of a thing to say
eight [inaudible].
Let me just say very,
very brief because I want to move on to
men and women.
The main man white comment was not
predicated upon my historical excavation
of your pants is based upon the evidence
Vitreo with which you speak and the
denial of a sense of equanimity among
the combatants in an argument.
So I'm saying again,
you're a mean man,
white man and the viciousness,
is that right?
Okay.
We recently changed the decks here.
Let's talk about that.
Uh,
another big factor of the so called
politically correct movement right now,
which is the me too movement and the
extent to which we've seen this a
resurgence,
this awakening around,
uh,
what have been a horrible series of
systemic abuses and injustices towards
women.
Some people though Michelle would say
that we're in a cultural panic now that
the pendulum has swung too far and that
there isn't a dangerous overreaction
going on where people's rights
reputations due process has been thrown
to the wind.
How do you respond to that?
Well,
first people started seeing that within
like two weeks of the first Harvey
Weinstein stories breaking right at the
minute.
Harvey Weinsteins and,
and people actually men act started
actually losing their jobs over this.
Right.
Which was something quite new that men
with histories of really serious
predatory behavior where suddenly losing
their jobs.
You know,
everybody had known about it for a long
time and there had been a sort of
implicit impunity and suddenly that was
taken away and it created this cultural
earthquake.
And as soon as it did,
it created a lot of anxiety.
Like what if this goes too far?
Um,
you know,
I mean the me too movement was only a
couple of months old when my newspaper
started running columns from people
saying,
why can't I criticize me to which they
were doing in my newspaper?
Um,
so on the one hand,
guests of course,
is due process important.
Obviously.
I think that when you look at who has
actually lost their jobs,
who's actually lost their livelihoods,
I mean,
look round,
it's people.
It's not people in general on a,
you know,
mccarthyism rumor,
it's people who took their dicks out at
work.
It's people who,
you know,
there,
it's people who there was,
you know,
10,
tens of millions of dollars of
settlements and they lost their job for
four months and now they're staging
comebacks.
You know,
Bill O'reilly is about to get a TV show
on a new network.
So the idea that again,
this idea that kind of like men
everywhere feel like they can't talk
anymore and everybody's walking on
eggshells.
And I don't know,
maybe that's true in,
in your offices.
Um,
it's,
it's not true where,
where I live,
you know,
and the me too movement has been
particularly active in,
in media.
You know,
there was this,
this thing,
I don't know how many do you guys read
about the shitty media medalist?
Um,
a woman wrote about,
she started this sort of open source
document where women could list men and
media that everybody knew about,
but nobody had ever done anything about.
And it very quickly went public and
there was something sort of disturbing
in it.
Right?
You don't like these anonymous
accusations floating around.
Um,
most feminists I know,
including myself,
were kind of freaked out by it.
And thought it was unfair to have
people's reputations held up like this.
But if you look at what happened to the
men on the list,
nothing,
you know,
they still have their jobs.
I know men on that list.
I work with men on that list.
The people who actually people have only
buy in as far as I can think in media,
the people who have lost their jobs and
lost their careers.
It's been four extremely serious
misbehavior documented by multiple women
who had corroborating witnesses.
And so again,
I understand this anxiety that relations
between men and women are changing.
Of course that causes a lot of cultural
anxiety.
But I don't know that it's rooted in
anything real in his view on this.
Are we in a cultural panic?
Is the response to Michelle says
commensurate with the very confused
by this?
I,
uh,
of course I,
you know,
I recognize the best,
the attitude Weinstein and the
monstrosity of his behavior.
Uh,
and it was shocking to me.
I actually worked for him,
um,
script doctoring cause it's called,
I never had the bathroom toe.
Um,
uh,
but I'm pretty obvious reasons,
but it's,
you know,
grotesque and I can't imagine how vile
it must be for such a powerful now then
he was,
I used to play a game at the Cannes film
festival where,
um,
years of power,
we're walking from one hotel,
the uh,
at the end that,
uh,
all the way up to the palliative
festival.
Um,
you would get 10 points every time you
heard the word harvey.
Um,
um,
usually a 10 minute walk you'd have a
300 points because it was Yo homies got
the script.
Harvey's got it.
Yeah,
I've got a meeting with harvey at the
majestic in the afternoon.
He was immensely powerful and I think
that's obvious that someone in that
position,
uh,
abusing him threatening and,
hindering the livelihood of women is,
is good test skin in the extreme.
But I have to tell you that there is
genuine feeling amongst many people.
I know
that we come speak our minds.
We can't actually speak to the true
nuance,
the true depth of sexual romantic
feeling between men and women.
It's not a subject don't absolutely
expert on,
but it comes between men and men as
well.
Though I know when it's men,
a men,
you might say,
well that's different because they're
women have had a different experience in
history and I don't want to enter that
particular field.
But I would say that there is real fear
in my business,
which is where this all started.
Showbiz does acting and so on.
Um,
yeah,
people are rather afraid to speak about
a piece of Vino,
a publicity that's come out or a
statement that's been made.
You just go,
Yup,
absolutely.
And wait for the people to leave the
room before you can speak honestly with
your friends.
Um,
and that's,
I've never experienced that in my entire
60 years on this planet.
There's this feeling that,
uh,
and I'd not characterizing feminists as
an east German,
but it's like that.
The stars,
you're listening,
you better be careful that listening.
Uh,
and that's a genuine feeling.
I'm saying that my hand on my heart,
I'm not saying it to make a point other
than the fact that it's true and it's
worrying,
but the sexual misadventures and horror
experiences worrying too.
So the two words they're not solved.
Let's bring Jordan in on this because
you've written and commented about a
lot.
Thank you.
Well,
I think I'm going to point out two
things again.
The first is that my question about when
the,
when the left goes too far,
still hasn't been answered.
And then the second thing I'm going to
point out is that,
you know,
it's conceivable that I am a mean man.
You know,
I mean
maybe I'm meaner than some people are
not as mean as others.
I think that's probably more the case.
But I would say the fact that race got
dragged into that particular comment is
a better example of what the hell I
think is wrong with the politically
correct left and anything else that
could have possibly happened.
Um,
imagine the hurt,
the anxiety,
um,
the insult that you might genuinely
feel,
um,
according to what I felt was an
appropriate comment of description at
the moment of its expression.
But imagine now those hurt feelings and
got her w w w okay.
You feel great.
You feel great about it is really
different.
I'm not a victim.
I'm not hurt.
You're hurt.
Okay.
You wouldn't be a victim.
So what,
What's interesting is that whatever a
non traditional feelings of empathy you
endure at this particular point,
um,
the,
the point is imagine then the horrors
that so many other others I've had to
put up with for so long when they are
refused to acknowledge their humanity.
Now I take your point seriously.
So you're,
let me,
let me finish.
Let me finish.
Let me just,
let me put it to me.
Let me finish my acquisition there.
Okay.
What I'm saying to you is that when you
said you were upset that I added the
element of race there,
right.
When I said mean Matt White Man.
Well,
what's interesting is that you may have
felt that you were being ascribed the
group identity to which you do not
subscribe.
You may have felt that you were being
unfairly,
uh,
judged according to your particular
raise.
You may have felt that your individual
identity was being a smirch by my rather
careless characterization of you,
all of which qualifies for,
uh,
a legitimate,
you know,
response to me.
But also the point we've been trying to
make about the refusal to see our
individual existence as women,
as people of Color,
as first nation people in the light.
My point simply has been the reason I
talked about race and that particular
characterization because there's a
particular way in which I have come to a
city.
I don't know if there are a lot of black
people out here,
not sure,
but I constantly come to places and
spaces that are not my natural habitat.
Uh,
other than intellectual engagement and
the love and the fury of rhetorical
engagement.
Yes.
But I often go into hostile spaces where
people will not vote in favor for my
particular viewpoint because I'm
interested as an individual of breaking
down barriers so that people can
understand just how complicated it is.
So what I'm saying to you is that I
would invite you in of the surrender of
your privilege to give you a specific,
a specific response.
Come with me to a black Baptist church.
Come with me to a historically black
college,
come to me to an,
to an indigenous or first nations
community where we're able to engage in
some of the lovely conversation but also
to listen and hear.
And when I added race to that,
I was talking about the historically
events,
inability to acknowledge others pains
equally to the one that they are
presently enduring.
So
the human being,
I stand by my comment,
seeing the sorts of things that you're
talking about.
I happened to be an honorary member of
an indigenous family.
So don't tell me about what I should go
see with regards to oppression.
You and you don't know anything about
me.
You have to make words.
I gave you a response,
you gave me a generic response and
generic race pace or scones,
Jordan Peterson.
I would like for you to come with me,
Michael,
Eric Dyson to a black Baptist church.
You've been one of those.
I would be happy to do that by.
Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna Hook you up.
It makes sure that
one more quick,
brandon,
we're going to go to closing statements
and for,
I want to get your response to why,
you know,
a generation from now looking back on
this debate,
we're not going to see this quote
so-called politically correct movement
in the same way.
Let's say that we now understand the
positive contributions of the civil
rights movement.
That that was a movement that advanced,
uh,
a series of,
of ideas about human dignity to people
who previously didn't have that dignity.
We're now having another debate and
other social data about different groups
and communities,
uh,
that are,
we're trying to convey a sense of,
of new dignity to them.
Why,
why won't this be in a sense looked back
upon as something positive,
a generation from now.
I think people will look back on this
debate and,
and wonder why political correctness
wasn't discussed.
[inaudible] I said,
if it's slippery,
I mean,
I
interesting to hear talk about race and
about gender and about to be quality.
And it's something that I've thought
about a lot and I can learn a great deal
about,
but that's not why I came to this
debate.
I was interested in.
Um,
what I've always been interested in the
suppression of language and thought the
closing down the rationalist idea that
seems beguiling that if you,
uh,
limit people's language,
it may somehow teach them a different
way of thinking.
Uh,
something that would have delighted the
inventors of George Orwell's newspeak
for example.
Um,
and it seems to me it's just
implausible.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work.
Uh,
and that's what I mean by empirical.
It doesn't stand an empirical test,
doesn't experientially validated.
Um,
as we see from the political landscape
now,
um,
and I worry that we may in the future.
So I,
I'm so disappointed that the subject is
just revolved around academia,
which was predictable because that's the
sort of crucible in which these elements
are mixed.
Um,
but even more disappointed that really I
haven't heard from Michelle or from
Professor Dawson as to what they think
political correctness is.
Because what they've talked about is
basically second progress in,
in our view,
is progress.
Well,
I agree.
That's,
you know,
yeah.
So it is too good on progress,
but
how is it
you saying political,
the,
what we call buddies is the greatness
you called progress.
That's what you're supposed to be
arguing.
I want to know what you mean by
political correctness.
Well,
like I,
okay,
the reason a few months ago,
right,
you,
you contacted me,
asked if I wanted to do a debate about
identity politics and then you presented
me with this resolution and I,
and I said,
well,
there's a lot of things that people call
political correctness that I'm not going
to defend.
But then I realized who I was debating
and,
and saw that there was a lot of things
that you,
Jordan Peterson called political
correctness that I call progress.
Um,
and,
and to some extent you to Stephen Fry.
You know,
when you talk about it being outrageous
to tear it out,
we're not outrageous.
I won't put words in your mouth,
but that we shouldn't be tearing down
statues of kind of notorious racist that
we should just instead be throwing exit
them.
Um,
you know,
so those sorts of things,
if you call them political correctness,
like call them progress.
Now this feeling of being silenced,
which I understand,
although it seems very vague,
right?
You kind of are not quite putting your
finger on who is silencing you,
except for a vague fear that if you say
something on toward,
you're going to be the subject of,
I'm not sure shaming the pipe.
Yeah,
but by,
by what?
By the Internet.
No,
but I mean
there's that element of it
here.
What I'm seeing is that it's,
it's a feeling,
it's a feeling that is this sort of
intangible result of on right.
Narrowly Goldstein,
the sort of show trial thing where the
person then apologizes.
I have so much to learn about sexual
politics.
I am really sorry that signed a lawyer
crossed out the name of the,
yeah.
Personally it's,
do you think
the real mistake of our left is that we
underestimate the right,
the right isn't as stupid as we'd like
them to be if only they were only there
once.
A cunning,
so sly,
so smart,
so aware of our shortcomings and I just
fear that political correctness is a
weapon that they value.
The more,
the more we tell the world how people
should be treated,
how language should be treated,
what words are acceptable,
what attitudes are,
what hr meeting is going to tell you in
a long bullet pointed list about how you
look at people.
All of this is,
is me to drink too bad people jump
malefactors.
The bad actors are not counting myself
as well.
Bad actors in that sense.
I mean bad actors in the other centers.
So there are,
like I said,
there were a lot of ways in which I
agree with you,
although I kind of,
I,
I would like to hear,
I need to turn it back on you.
I'd like to hear you say,
you know,
what are the words that have fallen into
disrepute that we think that you think
we should be resurrecting?
Right.
I mean,
to me this is this area of like hotly
contested social change right now where
a lot of people feel
wounds that have gone into disuse.
It's very often freezes,
jargonistic,
slew goodness,
heteronormative,
CIS gendered,
um,
those kinds of things that they're just
an insult.
You know,
imagine you're a young student arriving
university and someone's bombarding it
with this preposterous hermeneutical
nonsense from,
from,
uh,
from misread textbooks.
So misread food cove and they say,
daddy died and so on.
Because,
you know,
I was at Cambridge in them doing it.
We had a French phase and,
and does
[inaudible] with that.
It's an interesting game.
And it is,
it's a place to,
uh,
I think I would just really say that the
ghost hovering over me is,
it's a lesser Oscar Wilde Rosen.
Uh,
he,
he said to buzzies love you said the
fact that you didn't get the degree is,
is nothing,
but you never acquired what is sometimes
called the Oxford Manor.
And I'll say for that,
the university manner.
Um,
you said,
Oscar said,
I take that to mean the ability to play
gracefully with ideas.
I think that's disappearing from our
culture.
And I think it's
Gerald [inaudible].
It's hard to beat a self deprecating
Englishman is,
no,
no.
I got a pretty good idea here today.
Okay.
But what's interesting,
I don't recall in all of you,
all of us have studied history.
I don't recall these debates about
political correctness happening when
people who were in power in absolute
power,
unquestioned power,
political correctness,
political correctness becomes an issue.
And what I mean by that is people who
used to have power,
who,
who still have power but think they
don't,
who get challenged on just a little bit
of what they have and don't want to
share toys in the sand lot of life.
So all of a sudden it becomes a kind of
exaggerated grievance.
Now the things you named the bullet
points and the CIS gender,
the Hetero normativity and the Hetero
Patriarchy and the capitalist resurgence
and the insurrection of subjugated
knowledge as to give Fuko some more love
or the Derridean deconstruction,
all that stuff.
The French phase is still going on with
the French fries in America.
What's interesting is that I didn't hear
many complaints of political correctness
at the height of the dominance of one
group or another,
but when Martin Luther King Jr who
argued for group identity as a black
person to provide an opportunity for
individual black people to come to the
fore,
they began to make that claim.
Oh No,
they didn't call it political
correctness.
Uh,
you're siding with those who are against
free speech.
You're siding with those who don't want
me as a white person to be recognized in
my humanity and what I mean by political
correctness is the kind of politics of
resentment that are articulated by
various holders of power at certain
levels,
at various levels.
That one of the beautiful things about
Fulco that I take as opposed to Max
Faber is that for Co said,
power breaks out everywhere.
I would think a person who's critical
political correctness like you would
appreciate this as opposed to Max Vapor
who said power is over there in a
hierarchical structure where
subordination is the demand.
Full coast had no power brakes out,
even among people who are in
disempowered so you can hurt somebody in
your own community.
What's more politically incorrect than a
black baptist preacher identifying with
the first century Palestinian Jew and
this still loving atheists?
What's more politically incorrect and a
black intellectual going on Bill Maher
and defending his ability to continue to
have this show despite using the n word.
I serve believe in a politically
incorrect version.
When I go as a black man to his preacher
to chastise my fellow believers about
their homophobia that goes over like a
brick cloud.
When I come into arenas like this,
I understand that my back is up against
the wall,
but I think
sit over here,
let's say I want to sit on your lap.
But what I say,
I don't get excited.
But what I'm saying is that he goes out,
[inaudible] been looking at me.
So what was it?
This
thing is that when we look at the way in
which we have societies in a free,
uh,
Canadian society and the Free American
society,
when I look at what is seen as political
correctness,
it to me has been a mass of jumble that
has been carved together out of the
politics of resentment that powers once
held,
no longer are held.
Freedom's once exercise,
absolutely must now be shared.
So I,
I am an agreements with both of my
gentlemen to my right who believe Vat,
a political correctness has been a
scourge,
but not necessarily the way you think.
So I think it's been a scourge because
those who have been the deployers of
power and the beneficiaries of privilege
have failed to recognize their
particular weight.
And at the end of the day,
I think that those of us who are free
citizens of this country and of America
should figure out ways to respect the
humanity of the other,
to respect the individual existence of
the other,
but also respect the fact that there
have been barriers placed upon
particular groups that have prevented
them from flourishing.
That's all I mean by political.
Correct.
Well said.
I got to give before we get to closing
statements and final words on this topic
to Michelle and then,
uh,
you,
Jordan.
So I think part of the frustration here
is that I think that both of you have
radically different ideas of what we're
talking about when we talk about
political correctness.
It seems to me that you're talking about
politically correctness.
You mean this kind of feeling of anxiety
that a lot of people feel because we all
live now in this terrible crowdsource
panopticon when you worry that any stray
freeze that you use will be any straight
phrase you utter might be used to defame
you.
Right.
And I think that a lot of people feel
that anxiety.
I,
I disagree that that is something that
is being solely kind of perpetrated
against,
you know,
institution to kind of Oscar Wilde and
figures by a since story and you know,
since stories left wing chord because
it's coming from all directions,
right?
This phenomenon which sucks is all over
the place.
I mean,
I get it when I write something critical
of the way that the IDF behaved in Gaza,
you know,
it's coming at everyone.
And I think that there is,
there's a way in which when it comes at
a certain sort of figure and there's a
certain set of complaints and you feel
unjustly criticized and feel silenced,
which again I think is really different
than being silenced.
You call it political correctness.
And I would like the culture also to be
more,
you know,
free freewheeling.
I think one solution,
you know,
you're not going to kind of get the left
too.
Um,
I don't know,
they can't kind of put an end to this
because it is much more of a mob social
media phenomenon then it is kind of some
diktat coming up from on high.
And so one really the only way to break
through it is to say what you are,
what you say that you're afraid to say.
Right?
I mean that's the only way to sort of
um,
pop this bubble or kind of end this end,
this anxiety or at least diffuse it a
little bit.
Whereas again,
what I hear Mr. Peterson talking about
as political correctness is something
much more broad and much more,
um,
kind of funded,
much,
much more fundamental to social change.
And you're talking about,
you know,
you want
me to define or one of us to talk about
when the left goes too far and if I'm,
you know,
I certainly don't want to be a woman
putting words in your mouth,
but if,
um,
if I hear you correctly,
what you're saying is that you want me
to kind of renounce Marxist categories
or to,
well,
I want you to define with the left goes
too far.
You can do it any way you want.
I,
like I said,
I think that the left goes too far into
when it is violent or censorious when it
tries to shut people down or no platform
then or when it acts violently,
I,
I'm not sure what you expect.
So beyond that,
something deeper,
how hard like you to contend with the
set of left wing ideas that produced all
the left wing pathologies of the 20th
century and to define how you think
standard left wing thinking,
which has as bell goes too far since it
obviously does on too far.
Of course the right,
well how about Auschwitz?
While I was talking about 20th century
Poland more recently,
what has gone wrong with the right
shots?
I don't like identity politics players
at all.
I don't care whether they're on the left
of the right.
I'd be lecturing about right wing
extremism for 30 years.
I'm no fan of the right,
despite the fact that the left would
like to paint me that way because it's
more convenient for it to far reasonably
well where it's threatening to go to far
identitarian Europe,
that's for sure.
It's gone too far in Charlottesville.
It went too far in Norway.
Like how long the list do you want and
why am I required to produce that to
show you that I don't like I to Terry,
so your assumption,
your assumption is something
how that I must be on the side of the
right.
It's like look,
the right has occupied the humanities
and the social sciences.
It's as simple as that.
For me,
if they had,
I'd be objecting to them.
Say that again.
That I didn't have the right has not
occupied the social sciences and the
humanities.
And the left clearly has the statistical
evidence for that is overwhelming.
Sir.
What about Iq testing in terms of
genetic inheritance?
[inaudible] here to talk about
political,
correct?
Yes.
And we've done a damn,
I gave you an example,
Carolyn,
redeem ourselves with our closing
statements.
I'm going to put three minutes on the
clock,
ready to go in the reverse order of the
opening.
So Steven Europe First,
oh Lordy,
Lordy
hide behind the lectured in that case.
Well,
I've been fascinated by this
conversation.
There's been an enormous clash of
cultures in,
in the conversation we've had,
you know,
classic,
if I can call it huckstering snake coil
pulpit talk.
It's up.
It's a motive
discourse.
It's a rhetorical style that I'd find
industry refreshing.
Vivifying um,
but I'm,
I'm not sure that we actually focused
on,
on the,
the point in question then.
My objection has always been towards
orthodoxies.
I'm a,
I'm a heterodox and,
uh,
an a contrarian,
then I can't help myself.
And I think there's been an
underestimation of the fact that
language does affect people.
It does make the young in particular is
they're starting out on their
educational or their work careers.
It makes them,
it makes them very anxious.
It makes them very angry,
very upset,
very alienated,
uh,
to feel that they don't know anymore how
to operate in the world,
how to engage in relationships,
how to think honestly.
So they,
they accrete more and more to their own
mini groups.
Um,
and,
and I think that's dangerous and unhappy
for society.
I think it's reflected in,
in the paucity of cinema and literature
and arts and the culture generally is
that there's a fear that's pervading it.
And while people can talk to academia,
and so you should come see our lessons.
Our lectures are open and free and ideas
are exchanged.
I'm sure that's true.
I'm sure it's true.
But I don't think we should
underestimate how much this feeling is
prevalent in the culture of
this strange paradox that the liberals
are in liberal in the demand for
liberality.
They are exclusive in their demand for
inclusivity.
They are
homogenous in their demand for
heterogeneity.
They are somehow and diverse in the call
for diversity.
You can be diverse but not diverse in
your opinions and in your language and
then your behavior and that's it.
Terrible pitching.
I,
I would,
I would say that I'm,
I'm sorry that it got a bit heated,
uh,
in,
in places because I was hoping it
wouldn't die.
I was hoping would be a shining example
of people of all different kinds of
political outlooks can,
uh,
speak with humor and wit and a lightness
of touch.
As gk Chesterton said,
angels can fly because they take
themselves lightly.
And I think it's very important for us
who are privileged.
All four of us previous to be here,
to be asked to be here,
to take ourselves a little bit more
likely not to be too earnest,
too pompous to serious a and not to be
too certain.
Uh,
it's a,
uh,
a time I think for really engaging,
emotionally fulfilling,
passionate and positive doubt.
That's what I would
[inaudible] we're going to put minutes
on the clock for
you please.
Uh,
your closing.
Thank you so much for that compliment
fry.
I'm used to not exclusively white men
who see black intelligence articulated
at a certain level of feeling a kind of
condescension.
If I came up here at Miss,
uh,
I was saying the other day,
but but a kind of verbal facility
automatically assumed to be a kind of
hucksterism and snake oil salesmen.
I've seen that.
I get it.
I get hate letters every day from white
brothers and sisters who were mad.
I'm teaching their children.
You're just trying to coopt our
children.
You're trying to corrupt them.
Yes,
I'm trying to corrupt them so they will
be uncorrupted by the corruptibility
that they've inherited from a society
that refuses to see all people as human
beings.
The death threats I've received
constantly for simply trying to speak my
mind.
It's not about a politically correct
society that is open minded and bet has
some consternation about my ability to
speak.
I'm getting real live.
You want empirical death threats that
talk about killing me,
setting up to hurt me and harm me simply
because I choose to speak my mind.
I agree with my [inaudible] and my
compatriots that we should argue against
the vicious limitation and recursions
against speech.
I believe that everybody has the right
to be able to articulate themselves and
the enormous privilege we have to come
to a spot in the space like this means
that we have that privilege and we
should be responsible for it.
No matter where we go from here and me
and brother Peterson would go to a black
Baptist church.
I'm a hold him to that.
He said it on national TV.
We're going to go to a black Baptist
church and have an enlightening
conversation about the need for us to
engage in not only reciprocal and mutual
edification,
but criticism.
Even hard and tough criticism,
but in a way that speaks to the needs
and interests of those who don't usually
get on TV,
who's voices are not usually amplified,
whose ideas are not usually taken
seriously and when they get to the upper
echelons of the ability of a society to
express themselves,
they are equally subject too vicious
recrimination and hurtful resistance.
There's an old story about the pig and
the pig and the chicken going down the
street and said,
let's have breakfast.
Yeah,
the chicken just has to give up an egg.
The pig has to give up his ass in order
to make breakfast.
We have often been the pigs giving up
our asses to make breakfast.
Let's start sharing them.
Asses what everybody else.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
so I'm not here to claim that there's no
such thing as oppression,
unfairness,
brutality,
discrimination,
unfair
use of power.
All of those,
anyone with any sense knows that
hierarchical structures tilt towards
tyranny and that we have to be
constantly for to ensure that
all they are isn't powering tyranny.
It's interesting to hear Fuko referred
to.
It's unfortunate,
but it's interesting,
you know,
because of coal,
like his French intellectual conference
essentially believed that the only basis
upon which hierarchies were established,
his power,
and that's part of this pernicious
politically correct doctrine that I've
been speaking about.
When a hierarchy becomes corrupt,
then the only way to ascend it is to
exercise power.
That's essentially the definition of a
tyranny,
but that doesn't mean that the imperfect
hierarchies that we have constructed in
our relatively free countries,
which at least tilt somewhat towards
competence and ability as evidenced by
the staggering achievements of
civilization that we've managed to
produce.
It doesn't mean that the hip appropriate
way of diagnosing them is to assume
without reservation unit dimensionally
that they're all about power and as a
consequence,
everyone who occupies any position
within them is a tyrant or a tyrant in
the making.
And that is certainly the fundamental
claim of someone like Fuko and it's part
and parcel of this,
what would you call it?
This ideological catastrophe.
That's political correctness.
I'm not here to argue against progress.
I'm not here to argue against equality
of opportunity.
Anyone with any sense understands that
even if you're selfish,
you're best served by allowing yourself
access to the multiplicitous talents of
everyone and to discriminate against
them for arbitrary reasons,
unrelated to their competence is it's a
Borat that has nothing to do with the
issue at hand.
It's,
it isn't that good.
Things haven't happened in the past and
should continue to happen.
That's not the point.
The point is the point my compatriot
fried made,
which is what we can agree on the
catastrophe and we can agree on the
historic inequity,
but there's no way I'm going to agree
that political correctness is the way to
address any of that.
And there's plenty of evidence to the
contrary.
Some of which I would say was displayed
quite clearly tonight.
[inaudible]
so I think one of the irresolvable
issues that we're all coming up against
is the role of feelings,
right?
Stephen Fry has kind of asked us to
recognize and empathize with this
feeling of being silenced if being
threatened.
And I do,
and I,
I get it.
Um,
you know,
I feel it sometimes too,
and my columns,
I hate it when I write something that
then,
you know,
gets a kind of irate twitter mob after
me.
But if,
say I stood up here and said,
you know,
recognize how threatened so many women
feel when,
for example,
the,
the kindness,
you know,
one of the best selling and most
prominent intellectuals in the world
right now it's t says in an interview
that maybe the me too movement has shown
that this whole experiment of men and
women working together,
it's just not working.
Or you know,
maybe if women don't want to be s don't
want the workplace to be sexualized,
they shouldn't be allowed to wear
makeup.
Right?
Right.
Well,
Google it.
See if it's vice interview,
Yeah.
Well,
so,
right.
If I say like,
you know,
I feel threatened right,
then I'm being kind of politically
correct and hysterical.
So much of the debate about political
correct,
but there's one group that really does
think it's feeling should be
accommodated.
And that is what we keep coming up
against is that,
you know,
there's a group of people and that to
some extent on part of it that feels
uniquely that our feelings of being
silenced,
marginalized,
censored,
that those feelings need to take
primacy,
that we can kind of,
um,
you know,
sneer,
when these other groups ask for us to
take seriously their feelings of being
threatened or their feelings of being
marginalized,
then we call it,
we call that we call those demands
political correctness.
And I would finally say that I think
there is a fair amount of research that
people become more closed minded,
more tribal when they feel threatened,
when they feel that their group identity
is at stake.
And so as much as you know,
you want to blame the left for the rise
of the right.
I think that when you kind of vet the
rise of the right,
the rise of people who are questioning
the fundamental ideals of pluralistic
liberal democracy,
the more those views are mainstreamed,
the more people I think are going to
shut down in response because people are
really scared.
Well,
first of all,
I think on behalf
all the debaters,
I think we want to thank the audience.
You were engaged a,
you were mostly civil and uh,
lots of civil in ways.
I think that we enjoy it.
So I think on behalf of the debaters,
everybody,
thank you audience.
This was a challenging topic and you did
it.
Great job.
Big.
Thank you.
You too.
Our debaters,
you know,
it's one thing,
all of these,
uh,
four give regular speeches,
but it's a very different thing to come
on in front,
in a stage in front of a live audience,
a large television,
and have your ideas a contested in real
time.
And uh,
again to all four of you.
Thank you for accepting our invitation
to
come here.
[inaudible] so a few final notes.
First,
thank you to the Oreo Foundation and the
monk family.
For once again convening us here at Roy
Thomson Hall.
We're going to do it all again this
coming autumn.
All of you have a ballot here in the
hall.
You can vote on your way out.
We'll have those results for you just
probably after nine 15 and let's just
quickly review where your opinions stood
at the beginning of tonight's contest on
the motion,
be it resolved,
what I call political correctness,
what you call it,
political correctness.
I call progress.
36% agrees,
64% disagree.
And again,
we saw a large percentage of you willing
to change your mind 87%.
So let's see how tonight's cut and
thrust affected your voting.
Here you've got your ballots and again
to the,
those of you who are watching online,
we are going to have all these results
for you on our social media feeds around
nine 15.
So enjoy the long we can have you
Victoria Day,
everyone.
Thanks for coming
the munk debates
and Stephen Fry Right now to get their
reactions to tonight's debates.
Uh,
some ma hotly contested moments here.
So what would be curious to see what
happens with the audience vote over the
course of the next few minutes.
And also for those of you watching
online,
we have that are running poll.
That poll again was ww munk debates.com
forward slash.
Boat.
So go there,
check out,
see how each of these debaters did in
terms of their opening statements that
are rebuttals,
the moderated section and the closing
statements.
We see any changes
there.
So again,
we're going to go right now to Stephen
Fry and Jordan Peterson get their
thoughts on how the evening played out.
Gentlemen,
thank you.
Thank you both.
We're just going to do a quick
discussion with the online audience is
watching right now just to get your
reactions to the debate and maybe just
start with you.
Uh,
Jordan.
There were some heated moments here.
Did that,
did that surprise you that uh,
the exchanges that you had with Michael
Eric Dyson?
Well,
I wouldn't say it surprised me.
Well I suppose it probably did.
It just team didn't seem like a very
good tactical move,
you know,
and,
and I stand by what I said.
I don't see any reason at all that my
racial identity,
he needed to be dragged into the
discussion independent of my personality
proclivity.
I would say what I just said to Mr. Fry
here is that it was a pleasure sharing
the stage with him.
I've rarely heard anyone ever deliver
their convictions with such a remarkable
sense of passion.
And we have 10 forbearance and
erudition.
It was,
it was really something.
Yeah,
and Stephen challenging debate because
in a sense we're trying to mesh two
different views here,
two different worldviews.
One very focused more on identity
politics,
group identity.
You in a sense having an argument really
more about the larger culture itself and
the tenor and tone of the conversation
with them.
I was being a little kind of scatter gun
really,
but it's got the gun and two specific
that I had just taken.
Very literally the popular idea that
correctness is being a kind of control
of language and the uh,
shutting done certain phrases or an
introduction of others and,
and,
and the,
the kind of day to day as I say,
human resource departments of
corporations and that sort of thing.
And,
and uh,
um,
so I was slightly disappointed that it
just became a debate about race and
about gender and so on.
And,
uh,
but that was I guess not true.
And I still think know the fact is I,
I,
I'm still a lefty,
but a software I'm just don't have,
I'm not too soft
squishy in every sentence.
Um,
and,
and I realized that that's not a
political point of view.
It is a personal way.
Um,
and the,
the gap between the personal and the
political,
which is a space you want,
obviously very interested in is this
like psychologist,
um,
is one that is rarely explored.
Um,
uh,
people that are either so personal that
it has no application in the outside
world and the Organization of Human
Affairs or the soap and the article and
so much to do with structure and
distinction between hierarchies and
networks and so on,
that they forget the individual.
And that's the space in which the
impassioned liberal lives.
And it's not easy to do it because you
often do son rather wet.
And I'm aware that I,
I enjoyed it.
Well,
thank you for coming.
He just finally,
before I free you to both to a well
earned drank,
anything left unsaid,
Jordan,
any,
um,
any point that you wanted to make that,
uh,
you didn't feel you had the time or the
opportunity?
No,
I don't think so.
I said my piece.
Yeah.
Great.
Same question to you is you,
I know,
I think I goes across her,
I mean,
there's so much you can talk about it
in,
in that field and I just wanted to leave
with the point that I do want,
like everybody,
it's,
it's a no brainer.
We want the world to be fair,
just a Sweden kind of,
um,
but it's how you get there.
Uh,
and um,
and I felt that wasn't really addressed.
Okay.
Well gentlemen,
thank you both very much.
A from our online audience.
A big thank you all.
So I know to Jordan Peterson and Stephen
Fry for participating in a,
yeah,
I had a debate with some steaks on the
table for sure.
Thank you gentlemen.
I'll see you in the reception.
Yep,
Yep.
Uh,
again,
online,
uh,
viewers,
we've now have a Michael Eric dyson
coming into the camera range here with,
uh,
Michelle Goldberg to get their reactions
to the debate.
So guys,
thank you for being part of this.
You know,
it's a,
it's a complicated subject.
It's got a lot of different moving
pieces and elements.
I think we addressed some of the
constituent parts.
Maybe start with you,
Michelle.
Um,
was there something on stage that you
wanted to say that maybe we didn't have
the time or he didn't have the
opportunity?
Uh,
you know,
now's your chance.
Well,
you know,
I guess I w if,
the only thing I can think of is that
maybe I wish that we could have drilled
down a little bit more into the gender
piece of this again to,
you know,
what we're really arguing about,
um,
particularly with Mr. Peterson and the
kind of range of progress,
the range of feminist progress that he
considers,
um,
political correctness.
I think part of the frustration is that
him and Steven Fry are talking about and
defending,
I think a fairly discrete set of ideas
with some overlap.
Um,
you know,
and one of the difficult things about
political correctness is it's a slippery
term that's deployed to talk about a
whole range of phenomenon.
Yeah.
And
closed down conversation and open up
conversation.
Don't ha ha.
How did you feel?
Uh,
Michael?
There were some points there,
a,
some,
you know,
points of sharp exchange.
We appreciate that at the munk debates.
I mean,
this is not a place for,
for a,
you know,
shrinking wallflowers.
Uh,
but,
uh,
any unsaid thoughts,
any,
anything that you want to put a point on
now?
I think you have to hold people
intellectually accountable and to deny
some of the things to Michelle that he
said and to present himself Mr. Peterson
in a certain way without seeing some of
the important things he said about women
and other minorities.
I think demands and engaged response to
him.
And I think that the idea itself,
as Michelle stated repeatedly and Mr.
Fry talking about his frustration,
he said,
we've talked about everything but
political correctness.
Well,
the reality is political correctness
resides,
I mean rests upon some serious political
work in this culture in Canada and in
America that needs to be done.
And what I tried to,
in terms of giving a brief genealogy,
we didn't have political correctness as
long as white straight men were in
charge.
There was no argument about let's get
this right.
But when people who exercise power,
no longer exercise,
absolute power,
still predominant power,
then there's an argument.
And I think Michelle's point about
gender,
about the workplace,
about race,
about sexuality,
and the link.
I just think that it was a necessarily
vigorous and sometimes sharply worded a
debate between us shall final word to
you.
Well,
if you are curious about the quote that
I mentioned about,
you know,
maybe this experiment with women and men
working together,
maybe it's not working.
I mean,
please do Google it.
It's an interview with Vice.
Did you know your columns for north one
of your columns?
Again?
No.
Me and Steven,
me and Stephen Fry probably could have
sat on the same side of another debate.
But again,
I feel like the phrase political
correctness has expanded to cover a
whole range of challenges too.
I thought it was really interesting how
much people are talking about their
feelings because when,
when women talk about their feelings,
right,
that is politically correct excess.
And when,
when men talk about this feeling that
they can't empirically define,
we should all,
I guess,
I dunno,
change,
change in deference to that.
Okay guys,
great thoughts.
Let's go get a drink in the reception.
Thank you.
I'm buying.
Okay.
Thanks again.
Hey,
uh,
online viewers.
Thank you for being a part of a this
munk debates.
Uh,
as I mentioned,
these debates or semiannual,
we'll have another one this fall.
We've got a whole archive of past
debates on our website on a whole range
of topics going back over a decade now.
And you can access those free by simply
becoming a member@wwmunkdebates.com.
Go to the basic membership.
It's free.
Uh,
and we have a rock solid privacy policy
there.
We respect your privacy.
So finally,
uh,
check us out on,
on facebook a thank you for the 26,000
new follows,
uh,
in the last 10 days,
we appreciated this debate will be
archived on our website,
uh,
for the next while again for free.
So share it with friends and family.
I'm ready.
You're griffiths from downtown Toronto,
Canada at the monk debate on political
correctness.
See again in the autumn.
Take care.
Good night.
Yeah.